hey poppy here it's Papa John and you're
listening to the h3 podcast go Ethan go
ela welcome everybody I'm so inspired by
the celebrities doing imagine that I
just want to spontaneously break out in
song because it's just a joyous time to
be alive today I just want to sing a
song of joy today's episode is sponsored
by nobody yes that's right nobody's
watching this episode we ain't getting
paid we out here doing this for love of
the game well we are sponsored by Teddy
fries oh is this shirt that you see now
oh is in your hearts this shirt you see
here before you is up right now on Teddy
fresh calm along with a couple of other
shirts that may I say are among the
finest we have ever made the fat now I'm
gonna do a read for Teddy fresh the
fabric I'm not kidding the fabric is is
among the finest fabric I've ever felt
on the t-shirt it's like reverse terry
it's um it's unbelievable it's heavy but
breathable breathable yeah there you go
all right how's everybody doing today
PewDiePie was actually so PewDiePie was
gonna be on today but then he saw that I
defended you i dubs on twitter and so he
called me this morning before we're
about to go live and he said you're a
simp
he called me a tent and he said you're
not quite a [ __ ] but I want to be
surprised if you one day go to the level
of [ __ ] dumb and he's cancelled on the
spot so I will be working on redeeming
myself in the eyes of PewDiePie the
ultimate Chad PewDiePie is a Chad isn't
he I guess I don't know I'm new to all
these terms I only last week heard the
Sam for the first time so the chad is
the guy who gets all the girls not buy
any not really buy any any reasonable
reason he's just handsome they say
Chad's have strong chins they have the
insults have this whole theory that
Chad's have a strong chin and that's
what attracts women so and then well you
may have not about your biology is
working all the time to analyze people's
Chin's with us today we have everybody
with us we are joined by the cast of the
HP podcast via zoom Oh welcome to the
show we've missed you
everybody is back dan and Zak the whole
crew is with us here today the h3
podcast there's a in this Ben let's
start with Dan Dan how is quarantine
treating you pretty good as a introvert
that never really leaves the house for
the most part anyways I'm kind of in my
element right now I'm feeling good the
best I've felt in years
really so I'm chillin are you able to
see your girlfriend uh yeah yeah I know
we've she lives really close like so you
guys are breaking you guys are breaking
you guys are making quarantine
exceptions for each other we are she she
almost had no brain size no ringing oh I
know I know she was really disappointed
no they said no room even a minister in
your circle yeah yeah um so how many
people do you live with Dan right I have
one roommate you have one roommate and
does she have roommates uh she does
actually she has two but they're both
working from home as well
they're the immediate circle around me
is all pretty fortunate that we haven't
lost their jobs at this point yet
we'll see how this episode goes today
looking at you in no I'm kidding
you guys are cold you guys are you guys
are you guys have jobs for life okay
that's good I mean I would break
quarantine too for ass like if mean you
work date is living a part of your life
I'm not I'm gonna go I'm gonna go visit
Gila I mean not ask me that's vulgar but
I would visit you okay thank you yeah I
would but you know I'm doing the mass
thing covering my mouth so when you go
grocery shopping do what's your
procedure uh well I mean well first of
all I've found because most of the
grocery stores are open really late I go
I've only gone twice and the second time
that I went I went and like 11:30 p.m.
and it was ghost towns they were like -
uh-oh Oh summers in there so that if you
happen to have a grocery store that's
open late like that I mean that's the
time to go okay interesting but you do
wear gloves and masks anyway because you
don't want to touch all that [ __ ] there
I got a box of medical gloves that I
actually had already from doing crafts
type stuff I don't have real masks but
you know they say this is still better
than nothing so I've been you know at
least covering my mouth slightly to try
and do my best what is that like a scarf
and then a hand sanitizer fabric I mean
oh yeah it's just man I just saw a story
not to bum you guys out but I was
watching the news last night and there
it's like it's good there's a 30 year
old dude they were interviewing his wife
it's like they wanted to press you as
much as possible on the news I swear to
god they're interviewing the wife of a
30 year old dude who died like the day
before from coronavirus healthy
upstanding member of the community coach
at high school and his wife is there
talk about how he died the day before
it's like it's true and I just saw I saw
interest
map today it showed of people who are
not travelling or taking the quarantine
most serious and New York and California
basically the whole North West portion
of the states and then when you go in
the south like the Louisiana Florida
area south east it's just red nobody
there
they haven't even locked down the states
everybody there's just partying it up
and it's horrifying yeah because we're
only as strong as our weakest link
because all these [ __ ] flora Dean's
are gonna are gonna be like they're
gonna come hang out in California when
we're all good hey excuse me sorry yeah
I know sorry everybody
I just couldn't get it out now
Zach on the other hand Zach lives with
his parents we sometimes forget about
what a sweet young man zach is green and
gold and beautiful as ever
you live with your parents and they
forbid you from leaving your house is
that right yeah my mom has some medical
condition she's got bad asthma and yeah
I've been seeing my girlfriend in three
weeks and it's been really whole see
that's that's brutal I guess that's the
pitfall living with your parents are you
are you think are you thinking about
moving out as a result of this I mean
that's definitely a discussion yeah
that's definitely uh there's something
to talk about yeah the REIT I think
people are wondering why you live with
your parents you were in college before
you started correctly are you our intern
not that long ago correct yes yeah I'm
only 22 22 ah yeah but it's been
definitely harsh not seeing her and you
know we do like little FaceTime dates
and stuff like that Oh tell me about
that you guys set up like dinner dates
yeah well do dinner we'll watch movies
stuff like that just we could talk for
hours you know have you guys sexted
I think we've already established that
they do oh I didn't remember the results
what are you guys doing that now in
quarantine I you gotta make a picture
work ya lot your internet lagging
about what I think he said is yes now do
you ever get real creative like
obviously you could just show your dick
that's one thing but do you ever like
you ever get like weird and put the
phone on the ground and like I don't
know you can just get really weird with
it I know what you're talking about yes
yeah yeah you got to see the hole like
nine yards picture yeah the hole three
inches so Dan is is able to get is
getting it Zach have you have you been
out and about Zach who doesn't the
grocery shopping in the household my dad
yeah yeah and see he's very he gets all
hazmat it out no just a face mask gloves
stuff like that the usual the
recommended the usual go yeah and Ian
who's in the Kanye West's house I can
tell you talking about this is just my
hallway man what's going on with
expensive what's going on with your
border you're all like interdimensional
I don't know that's the part of the
house it's a feature
so then quarantine life is good he's
chilling in a giant mansion in Calabasas
I'm just chillin in Calabasas so Ian
house corns have been treating you it
hasn't been too bad um see you don't
stay busy real crazy yeah that it's too
bad that she's you know so far away but
it's not cuz of the quarantine this is
how we've been living you know long
distance that's how you do it so well I
I wonder if she would have stayed a week
longer if she may have been like
stranded with you have you thought about
that
well if if she couldn't have you know
that have been great is I mean I have
people that I live with too so you kind
of have to go through the chain of
command to confirm stuff like that but
if it's due to a natural incident I'm
like oh sorry well are your your your
housemates would would veto your
girlfriend staying there is it we have
that draconian laws over in the house
well I mean she was here for almost two
weeks and I was a long time yeah it's
you know it's getting up there okay okay
you're you're considerate you're
considerate housemate are you are there
any weak links in your house where
you're like oh that guy is not taking
this quarantine as serious as he should
be no cuz right now it's just me and in
one other one other person cuz our third
moved out to two weeks ago week ago so
that happened because of the quarantine
right no they this they had got outta
place before though we had a replacement
to take their room and then that guy got
laid off at his job and said I can't I
can't afford anymore I'm moving back
home so yeah
currently figuring that out we we have
someone lined up but they won't be there
til til May so okay well that's good
yeah but quarantine no quarantines been
it's been fine been working a lot
oh you by the way Ian edited our last
dumb products video so give it up to
young yeah that was the first video
edited for us I mean he's done a bunch
of little edits here and there on goofs
and gaffes but I really think you got a
knack for uh for the editing for the
comedy the editing the effects of the
eye it's there can I can I share what
happened when I got the footage so I I
went to your guys's place and I picked
up a SD card with footage on it oh that
yes and I bring it back and I put it in
and it's all labeled that date so they
must have just put that as the date when
you guys transferred it over I think you
did that what I didn't do anything I was
always wondering why you even opened it
because that footage was shot like a
year ago yeah it all said March 2020
every file weird yeah so I just load it
all up I assumed it was all related to
the video and I start scrubbing through
it and then there
Ethan's in the bathroom and he's
shirtless no so he he's like doing an ad
what was the ad for I'm trying to pull
the video of what video was it for
because uh because I remember I remember
when we were shooting it me neither were
like I've never first of all my whole
life I've never filmed anything like
that and and he was like don't worry or
I mean I was like we'll just edit it out
but me and Ellis said to each other at
the time this is curse this footage was
so cursed but wait which video was it
because I want to pull it up so he was
like an ad for like Dollar Shave Club
yeah right yeah yeah so he's uh shaving
himself in his chest and then at one
point he turns to ela and goes don't
worry we'll just cut this out later and
then pulls his pants down and I saw
everything
I remember my dick was really small
because I remember looking at it and I
was like I usually show better than this
but it's just Allah and nobody's ever
gonna see this right away I looked I
like the top right of the screen and
just peripheral was like okay yeah that
that was a penis but actually it wasn't
the way I remember is that here I'm
gonna play it for you now because the
way I remember it is that it was like
underneath looking up at my balls from
my ass it was like crazy shots
I'm playing it on my computer there yeah
yes so here I did a shot where I was
shaving my [ __ ] did you see that one
or you just saw me take my weight no I
didn't see any [ __ ] so you didn't eat
eating less either thankfully you didn't
even see the worst of it which is on my
screen right here worse yeah it got
worse was it the wrong card or this was
just old footage so it was a it was the
card on the ATD the one that we do like
the second shots okay handheld and I
think we made this video maybe a year
ago like can you check yeah yeah I'll
tell you the date so normally when we're
into making videos every week March 19
almost more than a year ago
so normally if this was happening every
week I would have remembered that I
would delete it before handing off but
this was just sitting there for like a
year and then now we shot it and I was
just like here's the card I didn't even
think about it twice
Ian did you enjoy it
the dude there was nothing good about
that yeah there's no pleasure - trust me
there is nothing I know exactly what he
saw cuz I remember distinctively when he
was shooting that being like looking at
myself naked being like I'm such a
disgusting monster and my dick looks
really small just saying this is cursed
good question ela well to be and to be
fair to ela I did my wildest dreams
expect them we were working with editors
like page three videos it's just ice you
know it was only a 'then editing and I
didn't have to hand it off to anyone
this is kind of new I remember editing
that oh my computer and cracking up
because it was just so obscene so I
apologize Ian that you had to see that
it was a lot to take in I'm sure yeah
it's alright it's it's I mean it's it's
burned in there for forever but so you
just saw the front of me naked that was
it yeah it was a frie little side and a
little ass section as well so how long
did you watch for exactly I I clicked
off that
pretty and then I texted you and was
like wasn't expecting this I still
thought it was for the video I'm like
were you pissed like a guy's what the
[ __ ] did you make me watch pretty funny
well I apologize no no one should ever
have to see that so I do apologize for
that good stuff though fun to edit you
can see no you did a great job I'm
really I'm stoked I I want to shoot
another video when I shoot one this
weekend today well today's Thursday
we're hoping to get this up on Friday
but I want to shoot when I've got a good
idea for one thinking I'll shoot it
either tomorrow or in the weekend I
don't know I don't know I'm thinking
maybe all I did this one I don't know
maybe I'll maybe I'll shoot two videos
throw in the Ian whoa get things going
in the pipeline baby you know how it is
Dan that's not your room obviously what
are you trying to deceive you know I'm
at home it's all good
why is your hair glowing purple oh my
god
why's it look like you're keyed out he
doesn't even keep up I got it
I like a black light kind of back white
thing in my room you know okay yeah oh
[ __ ]
wait what's happening
wait are you in the podcast room I mean
well cuz it still looks oh you are in
the podcast room you alright what
there's all the kinds of garbage back
there I've been living on that couch
there's like a bottle over lockroy and
chip bags hold on it here or wait hold
on no I'm just I'm chilling I'm sure no
no guys no big deal
dan is living on the on the couch at the
podcast studio is it don't you have a
better place to crash than that not that
I mind I'm just I mean have you laid
down on this couch it is comfortable
it's like it's legit this is better than
my apartment
I don't know there's nobody here I
figured so you're a Nathan fit that's
funny
what does that mean Dan is that some
kind of psychological thing you're
sitting in my seat you're the butt guys
video what's going on give some
unresolved issues
I am the podcast now it still looks so
fake but I can tell it's not because
it's not yes by the way they did say hi
so is this officially the worst podcast
for me today
may-maybe here let's watch Dan eat chips
yeah did you do the chip voice yes the
AI advanced AI got grunt we call the bag
crinkling bat I think that was Skype
pumping zoom has they'll have the
technology over at zoom yet so they're
working on that
well we've caught up with the guys they
will be on the call with us as we go
through our episode today chiming in as
they see fit so the guys are here with
us ever present not only in our hearts
and minds but in physical bodies as well
so that's exciting
excuse me I got a subdued into the mic
well we have a lot to get to and I feel
like we just talked oh my god they want
to see is wrong cuz I feel like I can
turn it off yes we never I have a thing
on the wall that the guys judge me judge
you as being awesome
let's see Dan like okay all right so
this painting well it's not a painting
that's here I'll grab it and bring it I
can't really tell what it is he's gonna
recognize your boy yeah you really
really need yeah thank you
you keep the type tight [ __ ]
all right accident bobbles what is wrong
with you there's something there's
something about this that is just so
unsettling to me that I you hung it in
your room and I wanted it it's Ian have
you seen the actual piece in person yeah
it's at a museum here in here in Los
Angeles who made them in wine this guy
named Jeff Koons yeah so you know yeah
so does what a big part so his attention
probably was to make something
outrageous and unsettling yeah it's just
so strange
yeah just every time I go to that museum
I just like stare at this thing because
it's freaky
I don't know did we tell the story when
we were looking at houses and we walked
into one of these houses well I don't
think we're looking at houses and um I
think it was Calabasas yeah and it was
like it was a nice house and you can
tell whoever lived there had like old
money like they'd been around for a
while
they had it there they probably lived in
a house for thirty years and first of
all when you walk in the whole kitchen
was they had slot machines popcorn
machines arcade games like total um
Vegas vibes yes it was like Vegas theme
but like kids kids ease to kids vibe too
and like an old person vibe because it
was an old person and then so that was
the kitchen had purple lights right yeah
there was purple ambient lighting
everywhere and then when you go out into
the backyard it was a small backyard but
they had converted the entire backyard
you know how there's like resorts have
they have like this fake rock landscape
for pools and a waterslide
so their entire backyard a small
backyard every inch of it was just like
fake resort rocks and
and just really over the top waterfall
and pool I but I the other thing I
remember is that there was a very active
beehive near the pool and there was just
some cords hordes hordes of bees
so that's the downstairs then we go
upstairs and on the landing like halfway
up to the master there's a little kids
room with like a twin bed or smaller
with purple um be I'm lighting under the
bed like purple party how its kind of
vibe but it's a kid's room but so then
this is when it gets really weird as we
go into the master bed actually in the
kids room there was a picture of Michael
Jackson or the child's bed no even
before we went to the house we were just
looking at the pictures he was like did
you notice that there's a Michael
Jackson and the kid's room and this was
right we're like okay whatever
maybe it's just whatever this was right
at the time that the documentary came
out too so we were hyper aware of all
the Michael Jackson stuff so then you
walk into the master bedroom and there's
literal shrines to Michael Jackson
everywhere there's like signed photos
paintings pictures and one struck to me
in in particular that was so bizarre was
a little picture of Michael G it was
like this big the actual photo yeah
right at the entrance of Michael this
big and then a wooden frame that was
like this big yeah I mean it was just it
was so weird that it was just so weird
and it was an old guy did you meet the
owner no they were no they were gone
they were scarce just like it was like a
realtor showing the house you know some
bad vibes that was the way but like you
had that had to be there yeah Debbie's I
had this like slot machines everywhere
hmm and then up on the landing there was
a little mini bar
stairs and there was a ton of dead bees
on the ground inside bees bees inside
okay move on it's like a twin pigs it
was truly like a twin pee huh yeah I was
expecting some like a little person to
come talking back walking backwards okay
let's get into the juicy stuff my good
friend idubbbz has entered the world of
controversy he has committed the grave
sin of having a girlfriend
no he has made the grave sin of having a
girlfriend who decided to make an only
fans account and for that reason we must
he's a simp and a [ __ ] and a beta male
okay now before we start this
conversation I think we should define a
couple of things to help people
understand a simple
I guess comes from simpleton is a
derogatory term used to call people who
subscribe to these only fans accounts so
they subscribe and then I guess they
somehow think that they have a chance
with her or like there was this one girl
I remember who like blew up big on and
had all these adoring fans and then when
they found out she had a boyfriend then
all the simps got angry because like I
didn't know you had a boyfriend you
didn't tell me that
I want my donations back whatever that's
a sin so so I should just chime in
because I too assumed simpleton was the
origin of this but I've since been
corrected that it's actually an acronym
so no way it is someone idolizing
mediocre [ __ ] or psy sucker or tohsaka
idolizing mediocre [ __ ] wait sucka
like a sucka
sukkah like Asuka oh no quite like Asuka
wait define saga well I mean what's the
acronym it's just it's slang just it it
can just be someone someone idolizing
mediocre puts I guess it's okay
interesting so so there you go define
what's a mediocre oh well Choji well
yeah Chad's
with big beautiful chins then you're
kind of a Chad yourself over there look
at that chin make it me yeah you're
looking chin so what do you call the
simps there's Chad's and then there's
what's there's Chad's Oh Chad vs. virgin
a virgin okay so the virgin in cells who
are having so in the world of the Chad
versus the virgin the Chad is naturally
good-looking he's got a strong chin
women just want to have sex with him cuz
he's physically attractive he was born
and he has attracted women by no effort
or cause of his own he's just born lucky
and on the other end there's the virgin
the insel who because they have weak
chins or bad physical traits they women
no woman will want them and so they're
so those were the called the black pill
well there's Dan you know more about
this scenario but there's the red pill
so the red pill is what what you say
when you're woken to the concept that
all women are [ __ ] [ __ ] money-hungry
and shallow that's the red pill the
black pill is when you go full Elliot
Rodriguez right then essentially yeah I
don't remember specifically who Elliot
Rodriguez was but usually I'm assuming
he was UCSB a while ago God okay yeah
right right yeah actually they
specifically cite him that's right he's
like a hero to the insult community
because in his confession before his his
uh before he went and did what terrible
thing he did is he was going I don't
understand why no girls will sleep with
me and other guys who will not even
treat them better who will not even
respect them go to all the girls why
don't I get girls
I deserve grit so it's kind of like that
it's a very strange phenomenon that
really ought to be studied by
sociologists because it's just so odd
the firt I feel like I have to unpack
all this because I really feel like it's
related to all this the first thing that
strikes me is the entitlement of the of
the in cells of like first of all
they're entitled to women because well I
think they they they just think well I'm
a man and I'm entitled to women and I
want to have sex and I want to be adored
by women but I'm not and I'm entitled to
it that's the first part that I don't
quite get I mean check dudes and you you
can make yourself better that's the
thing I mean you know when you look at
Elliott Rodriguez for example he was a
handsome guy he wasn't a bad-looking guy
he was in shape I think really the dude
is just a lot of these it's like the
nice guy syndrome which is another one
where it's like I'm gonna treat you
better than any other guy
yada-yada-yada I love you better than
any other guy my treat you right and
then the minute they sense they get
insecure or since any type of rejection
they go
[ __ ] you [ __ ] you're a [ __ ] I would
never [ __ ] you anyway that whole thing
right so it's a it's a to me the whole
concept just doesn't make any sense
because it's like it's all everything is
so subjective
I don't know whoever I'm gonna find to
be the right person for me is not what
these guys are thinking it's not like I
it's not like every girl wants to be
with that guy that they think is the
child no and and also let me say that as
a guy dude who wants to find an
attractive spouse
trust me it's way better being a guy
because you can be beat ass ugly and fun
and you guys are dating up all the time
every day even right now there's a guy
out there
dating way up me date it way up women
they date down women date down it's just
a matter of fact it's just a matter of
life because women can look past certain
things it's not like oh I just needs to
look like this so I'm not even gonna
look at him it's just not like that this
is so cute this bracelet thank you
you should show that it's like gummy
bear bracelet so say so so but but so
the thing that women look for men is
what you kind of traditionally expect in
the long term I mean if you're in
college and you're trying to get [ __ ]
I mean girls aren't necessarily trying
to get married okay so you might have to
[ __ ] a fat chick if you're really that
beat so what is that's another thing
about these in cells we don't want to
settle they wants ends exactly like okay
who said that that's bad who said that
girls are not [ __ ] a fat guy like
what's girls [ __ ] fat guys today okay
some point it's just a hole well it's
just a hole everything about it is so
wrong to me I just can't even begin to
understand well so here's the problem
again it's the internet okay before the
internet you had these spiteful angry in
cells who wanted to [ __ ] tens but could
only pull threes and so they hate they
hate these threes because they think
they're worthy of the 10 but now you got
these communities and they're having
their defining they got the red pill
they're gonna blackmail you've got all
these theories about chins and chad's
and then all the sudden it becomes like
a it becomes like a discipline becomes a
study and that's the problem with the
internet right makes these outsiders
feel like they belong to a community and
these phenomenons become to become
manifested into the world but women are
looking for you know good fathers good
providers people who are nurturing
having a good I mean all these things
right you can overcome bad looks also
you can exercise you can dress nice you
can shave and do your hair and sure
there's a lot you can do
to make yourself can be a lot simpler
than that just someone who you connect
with like you guys like the same things
you like the same music you like the
same what else that's not helpful
because they'll just look at a 10 and be
like well we like the same movies we'd
like the same music and then they're
like oh he's friendzone obviously and
then all of a sudden it's like hey do
you want to go out she goes no you're
not my type because I [ __ ] you are
such a [ __ ] you led me on I hope that
you date a guy that beat you and raped
and they'll start saying oh that's it
right only ten you got to know your you
got to know what you can date bro dance
background so ya know she just heard Dan
is eating chips by the way anything that
was muted I just saw a silver Konya
staring at me you got to know look you
gotta be real dude you got to be real
okay
me myself at my best I'll say like right
now probably in my current shape I'm
probably like a three no I mean listen
you know that because you're not a three
I'm just saying I mean if I'm dating in
the world right now and let's say I
don't have money or fame - it's tough
but I it's tough okay but if I've
cleaned up and I was looking my best
physically speaking only I can maybe
achieve a six at best okay but that's
enough to work with as a guy yeah I mean
where everyone wants to be a 10/10 Brad
Pitt there's like one time you're not a
ten bro you never will be you say if you
can be a [ __ ] I don't want to be a ten
clean yourself up to a five because
these people haven't developed out of
middle school I remember in middle
school you're like all these handsome
guys all the girls want the same cube
boys and I want those girls and it's not
fair because you're not you don't having
developed you even it's like they never
got past that so this is a long way
around coming back to the items
controversy is that I feel like there
are a lot of immature there's two camps
really there's like the N cells and then
there's like the Puritans which somehow
is a thing now in this society where
West or where it well Puritans it's like
a it's like they believe that women must
be pure and if you show your titties to
the world then your titties have less
value to your man you know like I wonder
what these guys think about their girls
wearing bikinis you know it's funny all
these these guys are like probably have
more in common with Isis right well the
ISIS guys they make them cover the
woman's whole body and walk behind them
and it sounds like these guys don't
think that's such a bad idea
well you know I'm just having fun here
you okay - yeah you guys might have more
you might guys might have better time
with al-qaeda so let me let me describe
now for you and the longest way possible
to come around to this the idubbbz
controversy the controversy starts March
9th when idubbbz girlfriend Anissa
announces she will be making a only fans
with premium adult content also she got
fake boobs dude
[Music]
and so the doom began let me preface by
saying that I've met Aneesa I know her
personally I am good friends with Ian
he's a close personal friend of mine
they've been dating for three years I
believe approximately and they seem so
fast yeah I know it's crazy
well think remember the first time we
met or was like when we just moved yeah
we just came here so yeah they seem to
have a very nice healthy relationship
and clearly Ian loves her and supports
her and so that's what I know about them
so but she's doing the but also the fact
that she's doing an only fence doesn't I
don't even know if it matters but she's
not doing like videos of porn so she's
not even doing news right that being sad
it doesn't even matter yes yes see I had
heard that and I wasn't sure if that was
accurate that that is the case she's not
no she's not even doing news actually
because exactly basically any Instagram
account these days of always like big
right no there's so many girls that are
you know have millions of followers and
that's basically what they do on
Instagram there's so much to unpack here
and I personally found this whole thing
to be really disturbing that that it's
such a wide held belief that everyone
has that there's some great crime being
committed here so so she so people start
saying that here's here's some memes
okay just to give you an idea of what
people are saying let's say you are the
chosen one it was said you would destroy
the simps not join them now first of all
there's nothing's not a cent his
girlfriend is making a lot of money by
the way he's if the closest thing you
could say is he's a [ __ ] which is
somebody who allows a dude to [ __ ] but
it's not but that's not but like again
that's
yes that's pretty far cry from what's
happening but that's kind of the image
of people are portraying here so you
were Spence abusive not join them but it
goes so deep okay so if that's a problem
then are all these people are not
watching porn right or okay if they are
watching porn do they mean that all the
girls that they're watching should never
have a life should never have a normal
boyfriend now
they're basically a lower grade person
that is just there for their porn right
that's what I'm saying there's so much
to unpack you're absolutely right I
guarantee all these dudes who are so
outraged I mean the majority let's say
I'm not gonna speak for everybody but
the majority of dudes who are
legitimately upset by this our daily
consumers of pornography so that either
means that they're not upholding
themselves the same standard or that
they're beating off to people that they
just hate and despise which in itself is
just so weird and sick right so
something that doesn't already make
sense this me was actually funny even
though the concept doesn't make any
sense that's true well that's a good
point too you've got the black Tamim
aneesa's faces on the little blonde girl
and ian is peeking through the window
which is funny but that's but if you're
saying that her has me posting let's
just say she's doing nudes even though
she's not plussing nudes on only fans is
the same as getting gangbanged on black
TOCOM I'm gonna disagree leafy even came
back and made a video and well and I
would show it but there's really nothing
to show he just came back he showed a
clip of Ian saying he in and IANS
response video he says I don't care if
dudes jerk off to pictures of my
girlfriend and then and then leafy came
on and said he just showed that he said
did you hear her [ __ ] [ __ ] dude and
that was it
and people loved it people loved the
video and I said well leafy you're
putting about as much effort into your
content as you ever did
you know I would love people saying
oddly if you come back I would love to
see leafy come back and try to exist in
the landscape today like the content
that he was making would never fly on
YouTube today and you have to adapt and
overcome the fact that like you can't
even curse pearl-like like I don't know
I'd like to see him try to make it come
back but and again I find it somewhat
rich
I don't know how seriously if he was
being or maybe because everyone was
egging him on like leafy you got to come
back and make a video on items because
his girlfriend's the only fans account
and so you know to give leafy the
benefit of the doubt I think he was
probably just playing into the gag that
being said he is kind of questioning his
his masculinity by calling him a [ __ ]
right I mean alright so I find that
ironic considering you can readily find
pictures of Leif he's with his gaping
[ __ ] essentially on the internet I
mean he has his nudes leaked and I'm not
gonna obviously show them but he's
literally pulling his butt cheeks open
an escaping shaved [ __ ] on display
which is probably if you're gonna if
you're gonna question a dude's
masculinity and the traditional sense
which I would never do I'm just saying
that was probably more feminine of a act
to say here's my I present to you my
shaved gaping [ __ ] for your for you
to take then it sounds a way worse than
anything that's on her only fans - if
you don't dude that's like infinitely
worse oh there's nothing wrong with any
of it I would never judge anybody but I
was only saying if somebody who is
questioning the masculinity of another
one worse to say to have a photo like
that on the internet would be would be
just kind of rich woman say so I would
say if you have a picture of yourself
your own gaping [ __ ] being presented
saying take me take me I'm yours to not
question other men's masculinity is what
I would offer to the public at this
course I would offer people do not
question anyone's masculine I would
never I would never I hate
the whole conversation about everything
I hate alpha and beta terms and [ __ ] I
just hate it I think it's them like
anyone who even uses it I find it so
unattractive you might if you want to
talk about being attractive and like
just don't even talk about this stuff
so done well that's the thing because
any but you're right cuz they in cell
community these whole red pills they
don't attract other women and they make
everything worse because they just
trying to be cool to all the other red
and black pillars that they're so they
become so bitterly unattractive because
of [ __ ] like this
that no woman no sane person would ever
want to have anything to do with you
because you are so bitterly unattractive
you're obsessed with other people's
masculinity you're obsessed with what's
fair in the world you're obsessed with
with all these issues of [ __ ] and scent
and all the end chad's it's like bro how
do you know you are the most unfuckable
person that ever lived yeah it's a
self-fulfilling prophecy it really is so
that's my response
keemstar leafy on dubs Anisa i that's
funny i guess i don't know the myth of
consensual sex this one's great this one
is great ela the myth of consensual sex
i Tubbs I consent
Anisa I consent that all the N cells
here
I don't isn't there somebody forgot to
ask I feel like that's very good
normally it's Jesus there right and that
mean format yes yes babe it's 4 p.m.
time for your dick flattening what's
dick flattening just stomp on his dick
it's just more of this [ __ ] ok take
flattening I was leafy in the dick
flattening well I don't know what I'm on
a peg right that's pegged I don't know
if that's flattening what that's not
dead flat come on you're still getting
dominated
and I guess in a sense the domination is
there so it there's a lot to unpack here
but in essence that the fact that this
has sprung such a controversy so much
people to say first of all people were
unsubscribing from Ian over this people
were outraged disappointed I am I'm
beyond myself and to those people who
are if they are watching this I want to
right now I just want to speak directly
to the Cameron I want you to hear this
you are the most unfuckable repulsive
creature sad thought you want you are
your sim Pro your simpleton your simple
mind you're concerned about other
people's relationships instead of
improving your own physical parents and
your own ability to attract women okay
your judgement of what but you are a
vile slime of a human that will nobody
will ever want you because you're so
pathetic calm down no I'm serious I'm
not calming down it's the saddest [ __ ] I
have ever [ __ ] heard in my history on
the Internet today it's sad it's [ __ ] -
[ __ ] care about Wow it's sad it's so
sad holy [ __ ]
okay then people say so then people go
what do you guys have to say so far
nothing I mean the the wider point about
these people that are I mean I come from
it from a slightly I mean it there's
overlap with what you're saying to me
the most disturbing part of all of this
is the kind of element of hero worship
or like celebrity worship which I
watched i Tubbs reply video or whatever
and he really he addressed this too and
I really do think this is the part that
bothers me the most is the people that
are like genuinely devastated feel like
betrayed like that one mean that you
show where they refer to him is the
chosen one I know that's a Star Wars
meme that's like the format or whatever
but they're like legitimately is a lot
of people out there that like hold these
people and such people like in in such
high regard that like when this
situation happens they feel personally
like crushed and I just think that that
whole attitude and kind of a
relationship that people have with their
media personalities with the people that
they watch is a really sick thing about
our culture and you know like on the
other like I think it's okay to poke fun
of it or whatever
especially since like and even even said
this in his own video I mean the dude
has a career lampooning people so like
he's got to be able to take it himself
and he even like acknowledged a lot of
the memes were funny or whatever so like
people you know dogging on him or
whatever doesn't bother me as much as
the people that are like saying that
their lives are ruined by this you know
what I mean or thought that you were my
hero and like you really let me down
here and it's just like the dude is a
[ __ ] youtuber man like you know he
makes silly videos like you really the
problem the problem is with you not with
him and yeah I mean this is a
relationship it's none of anybody's
business and just you just shouldn't
care that much it just doesn't [ __ ]
matter you know well the hero worship is
one thing but like even before you come
to that point for them to be that
bitterly disappointed means that he did
something unforgivable and what was that
unforgivable thing right that's his
girlfriend
someone said allowing quote he's the
word allowing so when he's dated for
three years who healed is in love with
who he has a mutual care and respect and
understanding for he allowed her to make
an only fans account it's just like what
makes everyone think that they weren't
in on the whole thing together they
probably talked about it a lot no I'm
sure I would assume yeah
probably made a mutual decision you know
when you were in a relationship that's
how it works right I'm sure that is what
happened yeah but so that that's what
makes them angry is that he allowed her
to do it yeah you're right and they're
very much that's very much telling on
yourself by using that phrase when
talking about it because it's like she's
our own person and like now and I'm sure
you're probably I think you're probably
getting into this but now like retro
actively people seem to be like digging
up all these things about how she's not
a good person or whatever and I gotta be
honest like I so I don't even [ __ ]
care to look into that because it's like
so I have I've looked into this stuff so
does it alone talk about next because
now everyone everyone who's watching
this who's super angry because I'm
missing the point
so now I'll talk to them so they say oh
well it's not it's not really about the
only fans that's that's just the tip of
the iceberg the real issue is that
aneesa's a bad person and they're of
course referring to what because they
don't know her personally they're
referring to several videos people have
made about her let's see here if but
I've got some I've looked at all this
stuff so don't so I'm well-aware lesea
so people are saying oh people are
saying that Ian is deleting comments
that is the dumbest people always say
that every time I see this and my brain
goes numb because you are you are such
so pathetic people you know YouTube has
been the same for doing the same thing
for years when a video is super popular
and it gets a shitload of comments it
gets it gets not even filtered they do
filters for spam but it shuffles it
shuffles the comments at the top always
it's always done that we've been accused
of doing in comments when we didn't so I
know every fact every time a new
controversy comes up then everybody is a
genius it because they found coz because
you're deleting comments it shuffles
comments it's always done that always
why so if in tell me this if Ian is
erasing comments why is it that all the
100 talk
are the same copypasta that he
apparently erased if he wanted to erase
it he would just block the words in that
he would erase all those and ban the
users you wouldn't see it why is it that
you could even accuse him when all the
top 100 comments are copypasta of the
apparently erase gone he's definitely
not erasing comments okay that's my
first point so let's see what's wrong
with Anissa the woman let's see here is
a counter-argument people say I find it
weird that if you asked his fans of him
using the n-word or the f-word made him
inherently racist or homophobic they
would say no because it's obviously just
done to be edgy but if you ask him if
you ask if him calling someone a [ __ ]
means he agrees that woman needs to
remain modest or whatever well suddenly
everything needs to be taken literally
so they're referring cuz people are
going now through all his videos and
finding him being calling womans [ __ ]
or [ __ ] or whatever even even though
he's never said anything explicitly
about sex work so they say this is
evidence that that Ian agreed in the
past agree disagrees with what this is
doing but this I mean this is a great
point right
nobody would ever accuse Ian of being a
racist or homophobic or using the N or F
word right because because he's just
kidding he's just being edgy but the
mitso so that's a good point I'm getting
to the anisa part here I just want to
cover all of the topics for all the
raging frothing people who are saying I
missed the point so here this here's one
there's one that come one guy said and
he although he's reasonable he offers an
insight into this puritanical
perspective he says I love idubbbz
and I simply have a stark disagreement
with the ethics of supporting a sex
worker and being comfortable with the
girlfriend using her body for money here
are some of my thoughts of those who
have actual interest in understanding
why people aren't liking this I don't
like what porn does people
neurologically
I don't like that we as a society are
willing willingly allowing people to
gain power and influence based on sexual
favors rather than infinitely valuable
things like philosophy science math
technology etc okay big brain on that
one well no he's he's I think he's
giving it those are people
neurologically well I think people are
doing that by the way - do you know what
I think a lot of the anger comes from -
is that like on Twitch and on only fans
you see a lot of young women who are
achieving extraordinary success through
really nothing more than being
attractive yeah that is a big thing the
hatred for titty streamers yes I feel
like feeds into this whole mindset big
time it that that's something that I've
always it's it's jealous because yeah
and and I and I empathize with them
because they think that other girls are
not jealous the girls are not that
attractive it's like okay welcome to the
club of not being a 10 well right but so
I mean I am pit I am Pathet it's very
difficult now and this time as much as
it ever has been or more to be young and
not knowing how to make a living what
comes next
you're poor you're working a shitty job
and then you see this dis girl who's
beautiful and she's making ridiculous
amount of money and in your mind and
also she's talentless she's just
attractive so I think that's part of the
recipe that creates this this kind of
hatred towards towards women who are
making them living in that capacity I
mean but that's just the way it is dude
you got to use what you got I mean
that's that's something that they were
born with and it's asset it's it's no
different than being born with a big
beautiful brain which you value you know
you didn't do anything to be born with a
big beautiful brain that can do
beautiful masculine things like
philosophy science math and technology
you know what I mean we all got we all
got this hand that were dealt with and
however you want to play it is that's it
you know that's how it is dudes were
[ __ ] the super-attractive bro you
think PewDiePie would be as popular as
he is if he wasn't like looked like a
model probably that's actually a really
good point all of the top male streamers
are generally good-looking guys you know
that's not like not like ten out of ten
in the yellow-breasted Chad's but their
dick off but it's the same in
traditional media yeah they're all by
the way I'm not saying PewDiePie is not
a mega talent that guys like a [ __ ]
mega talent hardest-working dude in the
game I'm just saying I'm just saying he
also happens to be yeah he also happens
to be like the most handsome man ever
I'm just saying you know it doesn't hurt
yeah what I really am trying to say is I
would have 100 million subscribers if I
was better-looking so let me continue
what I do like about this guy's reply
though is that he is very polite so I do
give him credit for not going insane he
says lust is a net negative loss of
energy energy time and even pleasure
itself via the body system of
diminishing returns this guy's brain is
huge porn use specifically alters the
brain and reduces a person's facilities
a man or woman has the choice of being a
sex worker and gaining fast easy wealth
that does know net positive to society
see that's actually debatable and let me
tell are disagree that's a that's
actually that's probably actually
factually wrong yeah I mean you look at
it like I've in in places where sex work
is legal you you see less sex crimes so
or by using their intellect or talent to
better the what if they don't have
intellect and talent bro I don't know
why you think everyone is like some
[ __ ] plate is blade oh she's just
she's good-looking and she by the way
it's hard to keep a body in shape you
know how hard it is to actually let me
look good to be a good pornstar also
requires a talent yeah dude it's not
like everyone can
you don't succeed at anything in life
without being good at it yeah I feel
like he's also he's massively inflating
the sort of influence and power of sex
workers you know when he's talking about
instead they're using their bodies to
gain Fame and influence the most the
most famous porn star out there is still
like you think that they're like this
highly regarded they're running for a
bigger in society right yeah like that
the highest-paid most respected porn
star is about at the level of like a sea
or d-list celebrity you know I mean like
this isn't like a premier industry that
you know it's not that glamorous so it's
like what does he talk it's also a heavy
trade off I mean it's not like you're
just taking the easy way out you're
trading off your privacy society that
looks down on you to like this guy well
clearly yeah let's see he goes on by
saying easy well that is not net
individuals men a woman who stoop to the
level against stooping to the level I'm
not sure that I agree with there any
level is being stooped to of founding a
career off of profiting from carnal
desires that hurt people as a whole
that's again what who is being hurt by
propagating lust and attack and lack of
self control will gain power via s Jesus
you're such a big brain ascertained
resources and become our bosses or your
politicians No when does that ever
happen the men and women who use porn
are just as bad okay so he's saying the
men and women who use porn are just as
bad by enabling the direct transfer of
wealth to exploitive people who are
often found exploiting other individuals
like children or the disabled bro what
plan are you there's got crazy and crazy
he's saying people who watch porn are
just as bad because they enrich people
who are exploited if by nature and often
exploit children or disabled people
why oh yeah I mean I mean I there's a
nugget there that sort of makes sense
because it's like yeah I mean a lot of
the sex industry is really dark and
there's a lot of shady stuff going on
and people being abused and everything
but um they're saying that yeah I know
well right I mean I'm sure that that
goes on but I mean that that is a wider
more pervasive thing than the porn
industry I mean that that's that's all
Hollywood do you know what I mean like
that's that goes on everywhere in
regards to the sanctity of a man's
girlfriend yes I do enjoy the
exclusivity that comes with bonding with
a woman I realized other men are going
to lust for her but I don't care because
the only damage themselves and I
wouldn't want to exploit their lust or
splayed my girlfriend's body well
knowing the harm it will do to her sight
psychologically with all that being said
I do wrong nearly every day I'm not the
judge and will continue enjoying his
content as long as it's entertaining so
this disguise obviously coming and when
I say puritanical there's a lot of
religious tropes here so there's a very
conservative type of thing with like
lust ink and the sanctity now again I
wouldn't be know if Ella wanted to do Oh
Noli fans I wouldn't be comfortable with
that
[Music]
we would we would have lots of
conversations about it and at the end of
the day if we're both on comm or if one
of us is uncomfortable we I wouldn't do
it yeah and that's how we do a lot of
stuff in our life yeah it's my point you
know like we decided to move here and
that was a big decision for both of us
for example yeah if I was uncomfortable
living here it would probably be a
conversation for us and we would have to
deal with it but that's just I mean like
I don't know it's that's just being in a
relationship I just think these people
are assuming that she's just dragging
Ian into whatever she wants right
she's the evil she's the evil just the
beta temptress
yeah you know just following whatever
she says it's like it doesn't work like
that if you choose to be together and
make it work you make things work
sometimes you have to compromise on
little things or big things or big
things but at the end of the day you're
doing what's best for you your your
priorities to be with that person
because it's the best for you I think
that well I personally wouldn't want
other do to see my my wife naked there's
nothing wrong with by the way if either
was like I want to make annoying fans I
think it would be a really good career
Avenue I like being you know maybe I
find that it makes me feel more
confident and I just enjoy the whole
thing then then there's nothing wrong
with that if I'm okay with it if we come
to that understanding which is what
they've done clearly so that's one but
let's let's get into what is wrong with
Annie so I keep getting a sidetracked
here okay here we go
exposed video man they've been exposed
videos on her forever let's see she's
had one comment about justifying the
Holocaust I watched this video I'm not
gonna play because I'm afraid you two
will take it down but she goes she says
that the Holocaust was bad but the Nazis
made lots of groundbreaking experiments
on their human experiments that's what
she said I'm [ __ ] hair just one
she used to livestream a lot this is one
snippet again it's like how desperate
and how how hard are you trying to make
her look bad who gives a [ __ ] about one
thing she said on a on a stream do I
think that she's a Nazi sympathizer who
said that no obviously not
use your [ __ ] head and he says saying
that we're all just one bad stream away
from an only fans account so there was a
girl who was selling nudes to help the
Australian fire who raised like a ton of
money and Anissa said we're all just one
at stream away from an only fans account
and so somehow that's her they're using
that against her I don't get it is a
funny joke in fact she probably had
already had something she'd I've been
thinking about for a while I think it's
a funny comment I really don't see how
that proves she's a bad person
apparently she traced over art and
claims that her own ear you tell me what
you think about this again she just
posted on Instagram I don't think she's
selling it or anything I could be wrong
about that she said I drew some art so
here's thought here's what she drew and
this is what people are saying she
copied I don't know if she's even
selling it so again like how are we
proving that this is by the way this has
300 likes like I mean what how are you
substituting this for knowing a person
and saying she's a bad person
okay so that's her other big
transcription preaches body but body
positivity and also fat shames people
okay who [ __ ] cares you know I mean
okay cool she's a hypocrite are we all
hypocrites like at one point in a life
or another they say a hypocrite is
somebody who there's a great thing about
hypocrites dan look it up they say
hypocrite is somebody who is just
somebody who hasn't learned something
yet I don't know something like that
type that you'll find it it's a great
quote Aneesa apparently wanted to join
Zooey burgers group and answer it's I
don't think we've and then there's
here's the big one is that there there
was a leak from a discord group of
Annisa bitching about idubbbz somebody
has even made a tumblr account dedicated
to her called Aneesa receipts tumblr
calm I mean dude my life like really
just get a life I don't want to say so
she had a private group yeah you could
say that
you could really say that she had a
private a discord that got leaked
what does private mean it was with her
and I don't know who was in there happy
friends or friends no honestly according
to these Danny are exact you did the
research on this who write or who did
this research I did the first stuff
together
what was that discord group that was it
friends or fans I was like paid
subscriber people as far as I could tell
well at any case it was not meant to be
leaked she was bitching about she was
having a hard time with Ian and then
this was like from so couple years ago
and now people took a private
conversation and keeps sharing it
everywhere to show what a snake or by I
don't know whatever you know people
forget every but nobody's perfect we we
all have a right to make mistakes and do
[ __ ] you know I said something on
Twitter that everyone thought it was a
total slam dunk because I tweeted out
what if Ian just loves and supports his
girlfriend did anyone ever think about
that
yeah and somebody said okay fine but
she's still a bad person and I responded
okay so let him figure it out at his own
time like what I don't know what I said
was that well clearly you know her
better than he does right and and people
thought Oh Ethan is such a hypocrite
he makes his whole career from
criticizing other people yeah and I
would never assume to tell somebody that
knows them personally for years that
then that I know them better than than
that yeah
Ian has dated her for three years I'm
pretty sure he's crunched the numbers
and decided he doesn't think she's a bad
person I mean we think what is what just
this whole thing I'm this humbler this
is a dark place we're in a dark place
and you know I'm pretty sure that this
all just comes from her dating in
and I think people up just because Ian
has that has traditionally been so
untouchable and because his whole career
is criticizing other people people are
always so thirsty to take down the don
touchable right especially in the
commentary community for them that's
like so so I think ever since it was
announced they were dating there's been
this wild manhunt on Aneesa and and
and this is the result of it right and
so the minute she made the only fans I
think every anyone who was following
this knew that they're like oh baby
this is our time yeah yeah this is our
time I'm gonna click this what is this
it's just peeing in the shower she says
I shall birth in and he was here and he
peed on my leg and thought it was funny
so somebody snip that and that's that's
that right there is them exposing her
okay he's a demon unforgivable I mean
look I'm not saying and so to that again
to that people who say Oh Ethan your
meteor your career criticizing people
you don't know I'm not saying you can't
criticize her okay but I would never
tell someone
basically what you're sick saying to
Aneesa and Ian it's that Aneesa is
undateable
she's unlovable now she's damaged goods
forever because there's only fans and
because of a few videos I've seen of her
and that make her look bad therefore
therefore she's a terrible person and
and and you look at we're all world you
know you can cut up all of our lives and
put it in a video and and make us look
if we were all first of all if we were
all defined by the worst thing we ever
did in our life what kind of world would
that be not even saying she did anything
really wrong I'm just saying you all got
to use your [ __ ] heads and yes I make
videos slamming people and I make them
look as bad
as I can in that video usually just for
the sake of the argument and the sake of
entertainment and making a persuasive
argument a video I try to be fair though
I mean there's a lot of bad faith people
out there I tried to be fair with my
criticism I would never just say it I
don't know every video I've ever made
but I just say this this is a bad dude
nobody should be friends with this dude
he's a bad dude nobody stake him he's
untouchable
I know but thanks to all you uh thanks
to all you guys who are blowing this up
and he says only fans is now I'm like
the top 1% and she's banking hard off
here guys is outraged so I'm not sure
what that means about what you guys been
up to
she's literally like the top 1% I think
we're crunching over she was making like
thirty to fifty thousand dollars a month
isn't that awesome so congratulations to
her what percentage of the people that
are super upset in leading comments
about this have paid to sign up for only
fancy thing what percent that's really
high I would probably say like I would
probably say like 40% of those people
close close to half of those people that
are talking about all of that it have
gone and paid the $5 or whatever to see
her not a dude I have to assume here are
the pictures it's just her like in a
bikini or whatever yeah you know it's
funny she doesn't do nudes apparently I
haven't been in there and looked but I
know so when she got her boob jobs done
she was posting recovery photos and she
posted one topless with like something
covering her nipples and now people went
and photoshopped it so it looked like
she's nude and they're passing that one
around as well as she does do news oh my
god people are so crazy I really don't
but like in made his response video and
it has 200,000 dislikes and people were
unsubscribing from his channel so some
people are really upset about this which
is just oh good
I don't intend for them to can I say
what's on his desk what's going on there
yeah why don't he clean up a little bit
for this video that's offending me more
than anything
peanuts some kind of Arby's drink tissue
and spilled it taste you en damn oh he's
got the same desk I do
it's the standing desk I love that desk
mm-hmm
bamboos and everything I think his room
is supposed to look like a dump I'm
assuming because there's like graffiti
out of that but um you know I think Ian
really did a good job sticking it to all
these kids they said people said he was
defensive dude what what does that even
mean people are saying to criticizing he
was defensive he's yeah he's telling you
kids he's telling you guys to [ __ ] off
and so if it sounds defensive maybe it's
because he's saying [ __ ] off I mean he
even even said that the jokes were funny
and he was down with it and he's just
upset about all the kids who are
actually angry and upset so yeah I don't
know man how many what percentage of
them are subscribed I have to assume a
lot because first of all to be so
pathetic and sad to come here and
dislike and be angry is the same overlap
of pathetic sad people that would pay
for our only fans account and I you know
I mean damn who the [ __ ] pays for our
only fans it's crazy there's so much
pretty porn why it's the same person
though that's what I'm saying it's the
real simp and look whatever I'm just
saying everyone's pathetic I'm not
paying for she doesn't do nudes for
Christ's sake and you're paying to see I
don't know I wouldn't do it you wouldn't
do it but I'm gonna call him pathetic
I would sad I would but that's fine you
know it's [ __ ] pathetic
how else would you describe
it I don't know II don't know what
happens there it's some kind it's a way
of following her yeah connecting with ya
at least what choice if you scoring on
her like that's like a Nick she's
fulfilling you know what I mean I wonder
if there's gonna be a Trisha collab okay
there you go huh squirting on each other
that's got to be a genre right smurfing
each other there's not what she called
it smurfing when she drank a lot of blue
Powerade yeah maybe smells up there too
that was actually the words yeah so in
summary I think I think Ian made this
video like I don't care who I offend
because here's the thing he's being the
same dude he has always been he's
sticking to his kanji stick of his
principles and he doesn't care who he
offends and who he just who disagrees
with him it just so happens that some of
his so-called fans are the ones that
this time he's going after so you think
he's being defensive I think you're a
sad pathetic [ __ ] loser there's no
anything about life relationships
happiness mutual trust or respect and I
frankly I wish that I wish that I wish
love on you I wish I wish that you would
find love and happiness in this world I
do I wish so have I said enough yes have
I said enough anyone want to add
something before we move on there's
nothing else to say I mean just don't
worship these people like or even like
even though everybody just people like
yeah it's true that's a good well but
also that ties in with the John Lennon
thing you know they imagine like like
these people are so [ __ ] self they
think so highly of themselves you know
they're feeding into the worship but a
backfire but that's that I agree with I
mean that's self evident right but
think so but like then you see these
kind of reactions and the people just
having [ __ ] meltdowns about mrs.
burrows about eating hating women and
Simpson City streamers no problem
you're just mad they have a competitive
advantage over you because they have
tents and you know hey Alfredo how's his
eye surgery yeah
alrighty what else you got yeah Ian's
exact do you want to say anything I
agree with your point completely
and Ian I mean dude just quit being a
[ __ ] cent oh who hates the good sorry
you know who hates the word simp is Dan
he yelled at me at the office
misrepresenting cuz at the office zach
is a soundboard like they had a human he
just says the same words like 50 times
and it drives us crazy obsessed with
DOOL DOOL DOOL Illuma I'm obsessed with
the new album that's the best part that
I've heard in 10 years and Ian you agree
with really yeah her musics good it's
it's a good album that's close
it's tough but it's debatable he was
just kinda he was giving it up for that
and then I threw him the curveball I'm
like what about your girl Ariana and
that that really threw eating off he
wasn't so sure after I brought her up so
you know if you have if you're on it
does it if there was all humanity's
wiped out it's just you Arianna and do a
do a liebe food you
recruit you don't have a choice I mean
you doll the hole it's up to you the
world is in your hands and I'll answer
yeah okay go ahead
nobody you first humanity's over bro
come on answer if I had to pick I don't
know man I out of the music I'd probably
take our music that's not what I was
asking you know I was asked I guess I
Dick Ariana that's right I think I
picked the doula Lipa really I think
yeah you gave me cuz are you well
Ariana's just Arianna she just looks
like a little girl dude I don't know
what to say
my into like the whole she just look she
looks like she's 12 do can I say
dude looks like a powerful woman's not
do I don't know her name what's her name
do what duolingo duolingo that's right
do leap hmm there was something else I
wanted to say oh yeah I keep calling I
keep asking either if I'm a simply cuz
now I just don't know like I go
ela do you want coffee and I'm like what
am i some kind of [ __ ] ass simp I'm
bringing I'm doing [ __ ] for you like I
have to be like extra masculine now to
make sure I'm not simple no you bring me
coffee
i you I allow you it's like oh alright
so we have some other topics to get to
obviously Tricia and Moses ILA's brother
and Trisha Paytas the saga continues oh
yeah we're just gonna have to get them
on a call because this whole thing is
just it's it's irritated and your
brother I have to say he's so unforeseen
that it
it's working me it really is working me
because he always goes he goes oh there
was just you know it was the quarantine
and my place got broken into and I
didn't have anyone to stay with and I
was like okay but I know you're but I
know your brother's not like that your
bros like self-sufficient he can he's
not like I need to can I stay with you
my place got broken right you know if
you he could stay with us
yeah you wanted to [ __ ] Trisha
he won't just admit that he won't just
tell me that he wants to [ __ ] Trish or
that he likes her and then he goes and
then he goes it's over and I'm not it's
not even that I'm upset that they're
together I just want him to tell me
what's happening
mm-hmm so then he think he thinks that I
like I don't want him to be with her or
something and that's not I just want him
to tell me the truth so Trish is [ __ ]
with us obviously you upload this video
I think it was yesterday mine for you
guys I'll teach you here we'll just cut
out for this Moses is tied up crying
behind the camera right now she's only
dating closes so she can get close to
any other hey love oh okay yeah in pet
debt yeah
huh and I'm Mad Men none Soumik I am
what's so mad Salma oh so mad so I sent
this Somozas I say dude I think she's
trying to say something here like what's
going on
again I'm not angry I just want to know
what's up and he goes he says oh she
learned it all on her own I was really
impressed that's all he said I was like
do you think that there's anything weird
about the fact that you just uploaded
video said I'll teach you Hebrew he's
like oh yeah no no that's just you know
like he won't say anything and that's
what's pissing me off about this whole
thing what do you think about I really
don't know and then he told us that it
was over and then she still posted a
picture with him but that's the thing I
don't favor if he's [ __ ] her I just
don't know why he's lying to us yeah
well I don't easy in it stuck I'm like a
goofy ass but but what what do you think
it is a question it's not really lying
he's not saying it's lie by omission
he's avoiding saying anything here's
another one amazing sex during
quarantine this is Moses I wonder who
she's talking about smashed on the fire
you know what she means by that this you
mean that he's living with her cuz
that's not what he told us well I think
what she means is that they're like
they're in the circle like in the New
York healthy
you know they can Rim together no
rooming Oh what is this she's got this
she's got the bejeweled Febreze bro look
at this what she has the Khloe
Kardashian bejeweled freeze get that
Trisha what the hell what a flex yeah
you know it's tripping me out about
Trisha how she's liking everything she
was in Nathan for you did you know that
no because I watched that's like my
favorite show ever and I watched it
before I knew anything about Trisha hold
on let me show you and we keep saying
she's been in every show and it's like
she will either early so she was that
remember how he had that show about the
security guard who loves big tits she
was the big titty girl that he fell in
love with a game machine in the it's not
crazy the game machine it's about a
security guard who gets distracted
whenever he sees a girl with big tits
and that's a reality she's pitching a
reality show about this guy because he's
so interesting so she's so young but but
again it's like he goes and then this is
from just like so recent here why do you
have to post pics on Twitter just keep
it private here she is with Moses yeah
this is from March 31st
Theodore's Hans is the das comet
you know it's not disrespect people are
saying it's disrespectful
it's not necessarily disrespectful it's
just weird that nobody's telling us what
is going on you cannot do you know what
I'm saying
it's like if like like why is nobody
telling me what's going on it's your
[ __ ] brother we see so we talked to
us brother like all the time he's over
our house like every weekend yeah that's
his new family
ian is in here I'm seeing on Twitter
that 69 has been released No are you
afraid that 69 came and took him out or
something yeah no you know he ins offend
but I am afraid that 6/9 gonna get
murdered out of prison Ian's computer
must have crash or something because
he's a he's gone from everything and
he's not replying to whatsapp either his
house got hit by meteors or something I
don't know
hey whoa so 69 is out of prison too bad
he's not here to comment on that let's
remind him when he comes back so then so
then the other thing I want to discuss
here is Governor Andrew Cuomo of New
York has been in the limelight quite a
bit since this yes pandemic has hit he
has stepped up to the plate he has been
giving press conferences daily he is
stepped up for the people of New York
State but something has caught the
world's eye that we must debate here on
on this stage does Governor Andrew Cuomo
have a nipple piercing oh here's a
separate photo this is good to see so if
there's something Hey okay so we have a
lot of evidence to go over so first
here's the one from heavy calm it's got
him waving now I'm gonna zoom really
close so here it definitely looks like a
piercing
so here it does look like a piercing I
agree I mean it looks like two studs on
either side of the nipple and so it's
hard for this one it definitely looks
like it but this is why you need to look
at it from all different angles here
have an image or album so here you can
see this is where I think it's a
suspender here it starts to look crazy
because he's got one on each nipple he's
got one nipple to nipple the same thing
it's a crisp crust so now I don't see
just two studs I see four studs
criss-crossed it looks like a suspender
because it's the same thing on his left
and that's what I'm saying looks what
are you talking about if you if you were
suspenders outside you look like a
goofball you don't look like a governor
but this is it's not even possible
because the suspenders hold defense
right yeah and he tucks his shirt I
don't know if this shirt stuck that is a
key question it is you see in the other
that he tucks his shirt I can't see the
bottom anywhere let's find I can't see
this oh okay so here it's tucked yeah so
you're wearing a belt and suspenders I
what is going on with your body no
exactly
so the suspender would be instead of
about basically or in addition but it
would be on top of the shirt for sure Oh
see here whoa whoa whoa this cinched
this whoa whoa so here his nips look
fine so it could it be just hair like
crazy this to parties all right let's go
let's let's go image my image because
you guys can't see my screen yeah are
you a major open so we've got the top
one the second one I'm gonna look at the
signora's waving yeah right now there's
a distinctive cross-section I sort of
see what you mean yeah like an axe over
his net
let's see it now he wouldn't be wearing
a lav in this photo there's he's not
miked he's just walking around so the
other prominent theory maybe I know some
dudes have sensitive nipples that get
chafed a lot on shirts so I wonder if he
has some kind of pasty or banding over
his nipple to prevent chafing I have
known I would be lumping lives
it wouldn't be lumpy like that night you
know it is kind of lumpy in just message
me my internet is completely down oh
that's sad well tell him what do you
think he said he said he's downloading
zoom on his phone now well but I do want
to know what he thinks about this okay
well what kind of nipple piercing would
create an X pattern on the nipple have
you guys seen anything that's like that
but I agree that that it's a lot of
hardware but here's the thing look
that's the only picture that looks like
that and if you scroll down a couple
more to the photo where he's like kind
of starting to take off his jacket so so
yeah okay so on this now are these all
from the same day Dan most of them yeah
because it was this polo shirt that made
it really apparent most of the time he's
wearing a suit jacket that covers look
he's not a snip it's above is not it's a
lot of hairy thing whoa whoa whoa whoa
whoa this is his net it looks like he
has moles or some kind of growth or
something or warts cuz that's his nipple
right there see and I'll also point out
if you scroll one more photo down this
is the one where you can see his full
body with the belt and the tucked in
shirt yeah and I can tell you with the
way not only the belt but the way that
his shirt is tucked in the suspenders on
the inside wouldn't be able to connect
to the areas out I think him I think
meant him and mrs. Cuomo get freaky in
the bedroom he's single
Oh on this jacket okay I feel like his
nipples are distinctively not part of
whatever you see going on that's his
nipple that's his nipple there's
something above the nipple which we
could be hair awards a mall short you're
assuming that he has normal ass
nipples I mean these things could be
dinner plates dude no I see don't you
see his nips are separate than from the
boss you're look you're looking at the
one where he's taking off the jacket
yeah another one jacket yeah yeah right
um so you see where they big bomb under
the UH
you see his nipple right I see that
other little bump down there I don't
know why you assume that one because
look on the right you can see is because
on the right you can see his nip let's
let's keep looking yeah hmm you should
see if you can find a shirtless pic of
him again I I'm thinking that this isn't
the nipple at all what we're looking at
and again what is all this forensic
details you've got here Dan I don't know
where this was found what what is
kendall Jenner pierced meant to do for
me she has my dearest nipple
it's so close up what can I make it
looks like I'm looking a lot like a
subatomic yeah I'm not sure see then if
you go to the one with the flag 2016
okay and look at his nipples those look
totally normal right which it goes I
mean that's four years ago and he since
has well I guess not divorced but broken
up with his long-term girlfriend which
we should really bring that information
in because I feel like she's it adds a
lot of new shades to this whole thing
what his ex had to say about the
situation right
I'll get I'll get so people are saying
it's this barbell but see I'm not buying
that because I'm seeing a cross pattern
but that I mean okay so we've got a
barbell why would you wear those to work
man yeah
wait you keep it in at all times you
don't take it out so Cuomo's prior
girlfriend so this this is very
interesting you and you're not gonna
want to miss this Cuomo's prior
girlfriend Sandra Lee who he dated for
ten years yeah up until 2019 posted a
video telling people to stop body
shaming Andrew
that's right body hair she's talking
take a moment and say I woke up this
morning to a lot of stuff going on
online a lot of stories being written
and a lot of nonsense being said hey and
I just want to say what a shaming is not
okay so the implication that body shame
is going on makes me very much wonder
what she's not saying there's a
misunderstanding right she said right as
a body shame but then my other question
is a pierced nipple that isn't really a
body shame right nope which makes me
think it may be some kind of mole or
disfiguration I think the dude's got
dinner plate nipples I don't know really
large though I agree with Dan silver
dollar pancakes you find me a nipple
that would justify that chair look trust
and I know I'm gonna watch this video
working so hard for all of our benefits
to then turn around a body shame shame
on you knock it off
do something to uplift people and make
the world a better place to not take
cheap shots that are unnecessary this
isn't helping Sandra but I know I'm
really just debating it's just a silly
thing everyone is praising him I think
we all just want to know what's going on
under the shirt oh by the way did you
know that Jeffrey Epstein and Weinstein
were like close friends
wow that's awesome I don't remind me
because I saw an article on the bottom
of that I'm on his Instagram trying to
see if there's any Jeffery up seems nice
didn't know the governor oh so she
doesn't deny that he's pierced the body
shaming thing really adds a lot more
inch it makes it more confusing I feel
uh huh well what do you what do you make
of it you think she's saying he was
weird nipples yeah I and I think because
it's an ex I think this is a total you
know caddy nice girl way like she's like
defending him
but really she's selling him out for his
free gas giant dinner plate nipple well
the fact that she's addressing body
shaming does indicate that it's somehow
a a you know a feature of his body right
and the reason to that I think that she
might this might have a shade of
maliciousness to it is in that same
article wasn't in the video but in the
article the people that talked to her
just asked her out right very simply
like do you know is his neighborhood are
his nipples pierced and she declined to
answer if they weren't like obviously
she didn't know of course no no but so
next maybe in her mind she's just like
um did I refused to participate yeah but
she went out of her way to make the
whole video she is burning in with all
this talking yeah exactly what does it
mean could have dismissed it instantly
that's the video here's the video that's
that basically sparked the the debate if
you're wanting to watch this here's the
video I'm gonna zoom in on the video
as it's playing swatch these emotion see
here it certainly does look like a
barbell but both nips I promise you I
will not ask you to do anything I don't
know here it definitely looks like a
does this make him a simp or a [ __ ]
that's fascinating
I mean it's fascinating the other thing
I want to add there's a couple more
things I want to cover my throat is like
dying I want to record a video in HD
video my throat is gonna explode if I
keep talking much more but the next
thing I wanted to go over zoom fails in
the spirit of everyone using zoom nobody
says anything goddamn I was just
laughing say something she walked
through the bathroom and she placed the
phone like in a spot that looking
directly at her too you know if I'm good
if I'm on a phone call and I'm about to
do something like that I date I like
triple freaking KwaZulu luck yeah to
make sure my shits not showing but there
you go
I noticed before we started and I
noticed that now they show you a preview
of yourself and they're like
there's a video all right you're aware
and you have to like click because I
think before it just starts just gets
right into it yeah that's how they work
right with FaceTime on everything so
here's another one dude is here you go
feast your eyes and this is trying to
say so they all said hi and just walk
the way they said bye all right so
there's that here's my favorite one I
guess so the a lot of classrooms are
taking place over Zune right now zoom
zoom is what the Boomers call it and
people are it's just a public link so
people are somehow share will somehow
it's a classroom they share the link and
they post it on like Twitter or
something and then a bunch of people
just start bombing the classroom so
here's an example of that
[Music]
it's like a million people joy there you
have it have fun that streamer black guy
to mad has just been doing this over and
over again I guess on Twitch good what
looked to me like light-hearted fun
the FBI has released a statement at
fbi.gov FBI warns of teleconferencing
and online classroom hijacking third
ovid nineteen pandemic well so i guess
they're not that busy at the FBI well
here let me read it I don't know if it's
illegal they're just warning people
the FBI has received multiple reports of
conferences being disrupted by
pornographic or a dodges do not make
meetings or classrooms public they're
just giving guidelines yadda yadda yadda
FBI hard at work oh this I thought was
an interesting stat this week March 20th
through 26th of last year the box office
the movie box office brought in two
hundred and four million dollars okay
the same week of twenty twenty the box
office brought in five thousand dollars
one hundred and seventy nine dollars
this economy is that was hard hit man I
wonder how do they get that five
thousand really but yeah I don't know no
wonder oh we got the Skippy video poor
Skippy I keep not be able to get to him
we got to start with Skippy next time
because it says could be next time and
we can't
without yen because he's the one who
edited okay so so that's really exciting
for next week because this this video is
incredible that's it
cardi B made a GoFundMe for Joe exotic
from tiger King the cut that GoFundMe
shut down yeah
Oh Jay Simpson says that Carol Baskin
killed her husband what
which is ironic obviously for all these
purposes
isn't that awesome you guys watch it the
tiger King Zack has I haven't had a
chance to you oh hey here's OJ here's oh
Jake commenting on tiger King I can't
look because I'm blocked so this is me
and not logged in hey Twitter well yours
truly I just got back from the golf
course where I actually played pretty
well now it's back and by the way I was
hearing an interview of someone who
played with OJ and they were saying he's
like he's like a super hard rager on the
on the face he's just angry all the time
when he golf's I've known people like
that like I used to play disc off a lot
and some people they they just get so
down on their selves and it's so angry
that you learn a lot about somebody on
the UH on the course you really do so
Perry is a very angry golfer listen I've
had so many people on my case asking me
to watch some show call tiger King well
yesterday I watch this show and oh my
god is America in this bad a shape
change about six episodes of this show
and I couldn't believe what I was
looking at white people what's with you
and while animals leave them animals
alone but it's so crazy you kind of keep
watching one thing I will say there's
got a shred of doubt in my mind that
that lady's husband is uh Tiger sashimi
right now don't you appreciate it it
takes one to know one
oh man I love it
I'm just okay I'm just saying how come
on don'ts here so let's see what the
comments that he's gonna be good yeah I
think he just blocked everyone that's
been talking [ __ ] yeah
oh geez Simpson Carroll Baskin locked in
a house together for a month would be
must watch TV so Oh Jay Simpson accusing
a spousal murder something he knows a
lot about and that's about it
que si telling oh this was funny no
offense to que si he's just [ __ ]
hilarious
que si telling a well here I'll I'll let
you watch this for yourself and you tell
me if you think it's funny
[Music]
[Music]
yeah I love the idea of someone with
autism they get well soon just great
it's awesome so that's it that's our
show for the day I want to remind
everybody that that what am i reminding
people a fresh yes steady fresh Teddy
fresh eyes are [ __ ] it's high quality
people that buy it like it it looks
really good
it feels very like today thank you the
quality of the shirt is actually
ridiculous also we're gonna giveaways
we're gonna continue to give away things
during this recession so the winner is
their hoodies that was cool that's round
one mm-hmm so go to Teddy first calm
our official teddy fresh on Instagram if
you want to participate in giveaways
we have no sponsors today the recession
is hitting hard folks we had a fun had a
fun at time though today and I thank the
guys for joining us welcome I'm sorry he
hadn't died halfway through the episode
he's he's gone
rest in peace Dan glad to know that our
office is at least going to good use
yeah I appreciate you let me crash here
for a couple weeks you know it's hard
hard times yeah no problem at all
and Zach you must be you are you yeah
you Zach is sucking out of those parents
you can see the girl for me it sounds
rough yeah that's uh it's pretty rough
yeah it's it's pretty it's pretty rough
you are you getting are you getting
annoyed with your parents hundred
percent yeah what do they do that annoys
you what are their thing what's their
stick it's just like the bickering and
you know I think it will just like
everyone the bickering and like it just
it just don't [ __ ] much like I mean I
love my parents don't get me wrong but
it's just oh no I'm scared like today I
haven't I've been fine for like two
weeks and like today I've been walking a
lot
I had like a full-fledged anxiety attack
today it was bad what are you worried
about I don't want to get it a [ __ ] man
like yeah I'm surviving I'm making dude
I'm just playing guitar and stuff like
that so I hope you get some really
inspired day they extend from the
underneath putting the phone okay
yeah send a picture of your manicure -
[ __ ] gave me well I was thinking
about getting my nipples pierced - so
there you go hell yeah I did there you
go what's the time yeah
over there how are you guys doing you
doing well we're doing good like Mike
like similar to what it's a lot to be at
home with a kid so just feeling more
exhausted in general yeah it's also fun
to spend more time with him so the dogs
are happy the dogs have agree they don't
know why we're home all the time but to
be honest I mean very similar to what
Dan said is that I'm I'm a naturally uh
I'm not an adventurous physically person
I do I'm averse to leaving my house for
the most part slow the only time it
really hits me is with fear that were
cuz he's like he needs so much activity
is that it's like I wanna go somewhere
with him because I run out of things to
do it in this house I mean the hard part
you can't go visit anyone my parents
can't come Cynthia door we can't order
we can't go out to eat that sucks um but
you know cooking's been fun I've been
cooking along that's been nice but I
mean look it's it's not bad yeah look
I'm not gonna look I've got a pretty
nice setup here okay I mean so i got
really nothing right shredder are you
guys going to the grocery store you
having like at home delivery delivery
mmm so what we do is when we get it we
clear the counter specifically for the
groceries we put it down through all the
packaging away
sanitize everything put it away sanitize
the counter throw that away wash your
hands and call it a day
yeah that's how you gonna do it I
haven't ordered out since it happened
though and I'm getting kind of antsy but
I just I'm so paranoid I don't want no
apparently not as yeah I said [ __ ] it a
couple times and and ordered something
weird like we was kind of weird I was
worried about it but yeah so far so good
I mean like I wouldn't got takeout from
a Mexican place and I was a man I was so
paranoid after his but apparently I'm
fine I hate [ __ ] - by the way did with
the floor was wet and I [ __ ]
a real at the restaurant the manager
came over to me and he was like he was
so I mean I hate [ __ ] so hard he wrote
you get one free meal on a business card
and gave it to me Eddie
well now got filled back all the way and
then and then at the end when I finally
got my order they're like I'm so sorry
you're a one free meal okay are you okay
that's the important thing
yeah I think they just didn't want me to
sue them I I would never use that by the
way because like it's just his business
card and it's he wrote with a sharpie
one free meal
I like if I tried to use that and then
what is a meal mean you know what is it
then I get aside does that mean he'll
eat can you imagine I go in there all
right so I'll have two burritos
and I give him the card okay well usse
loves a big for the other burrito it's
one meal here's one meal I you tell me I
ate [ __ ] neither can't get two free
burritos so I threw it up I saw the
whole thing blowing out my mind
yeah maybe we should go get some takeout
Mexican food I love that they do say
that there haven't really been
infections through like that's what a
doctor I guess was saying right so
that's just throw the packaging now yeah
take the food yeah dr. agus was funny he
goes Howard's like so if you microwave
it for 15 seconds doesn't kill the virus
he goes I would say put in the microwave
if you want your food warm you know
Ian's got a poster of bubbles and
Michael Anna's room other picture of
Howard Stern
I don't know move your camera yeah
it's a alright well guys thank you for
joining us thank you everybody for
watching I hope that your quarantine is
going well I'm gonna be pushing myself
to the limit to bring you entertaining
content to help us through these
troubled times I'm gonna make another
extra cute video we're gonna keep making
podcasts we're not going anywhere
yeah same thing where they are pretty
fresh we're really trying to adjust to
the situation it's not easy
try not to lay anybody off all of our
employees not you guys you guys
obviously this 20 employees on Teddy
fresh we were also like we had no photo
sure but clearly you can do a photo
shoot so we were thinking what's a
creative idea and then we ended up just
sending the clothing to the models that
we were gonna use and just instructing
them and they shot themselves in the
requirement and came out really good
yeah really good weight trying to work
with what we got a lot of deliveries
were being pushed to so it's all coming
like everything we plan is changing the
best laid plans of mice and sims are you
since my angel wisdom but into alpha
Chad there he is look at him he's such
an alpha Chad he's office bug yeah he is
alrighty so guys stay well keep your
spirits up you know this will all be a
distant memory soon mm-hmm you know like
9/11 I mean everybody's like uh
everyone's making jokes about 9/11 now
you know it'll be like that soon it'll
be like all kinds of corona memes like
imagine the corona memes they're gonna
come out of this like I survived the
corona virus and all I got was this
t-shirt damn can't wait for that one
that's gonna be sick
Rock that shirt is soon I don't know man
[Music]
well my prediction is that what our
whole-wheat we here in the United States
I think around the globe it's gonna be
something like in in the really
impoverished parts of the other globe in
Africa and South America and Russia well
so he comes back
those places are gonna be [ __ ] for a
long long long time basically I don't
think it will ever go away actually I
think that we will need a vaccine and
then until then it will just never go
away
but in in the United States and
countries where we have the resources
and about three months time I'm guessing
it will start to decline
once it declines enough to the point
where there's very very little new cases
you can contact trace right so once
somebody gets diagnosed then you can
quarantine them and contact trace and
contain the spread that's what they're
doing other countries like Japan and and
Korea China etc so once you once you get
it right right now the United States is
completely under control because our our
response here was so slow out the gate
so out of control here because our
response was so slow that now so
widespread there's just there's no way
to contact spread there's no way to
contact trace there's no way to really
quarantine individuals that's what we're
all just it's like everybody's
quarantine so in about three months
you're gonna start seeing a it
normalizing and then from that point on
I think we'll be able to maintain it
until a vaccine comes around I wonder if
it's ever gonna go back to normal in the
way that we do stuff like like now any
Amazon package that comes in I like I
live it out for a day and then I open it
outside and I immediately throw the Box
in the trash
I think so in a couple years though it
will be a while mm-hm
yeah you know I saw something crazy this
church in Jerusalem closed and only
closed two times one was during the
Black Plague and the second was
coronavirus yeah it was the Holy
Sepulchre where Jesus apparently rose
from the dead yeah that's crazy yeah the
black plagues are good can you imagined
it if the matter if the mortality rate
was like 40% like the Black Plague
people would be like peace out staying
inside [ __ ] now everyone's just
like old people be damned but if your
ass had a 40% chance of dying I'd be
like peace nobody's a piece I'm sitting
by the door with my shotgun you know but
it's insidious because this coronavirus
is gonna it's a deadly [ __ ] and
it's like people it's just like Oh 2%
you imagine dude you're gonna roll a
dice if you have a 2% chance of dying
nobody wants to roll that dice that's a
little too [ __ ] high chance
probability for my taste but it's just
low enough so that people don't take it
seriously and it's able to keep
spreading if it was higher everyone
would be like [ __ ] this [ __ ] I'm out 10%
no closable fight nobody comes Laos 2%
Spring Break baby you know the rain
that's the show all right so thank you
everybody
thank you for joining us hope you were
entertained I hope that you did we can't
do these these closes like further let's
just end it thank you guys we love you
and we'll see you next week
appreciate you
[Music]